some in the suit  some in the suit what are you saying the  suit the suit and keep this safe  so be it  get it  [Music]  that was awesome  foreign  stephen  what are you are you like living inside  of me it's a little more complicated  than that  [Music]  mark you look different  [Music]  we protect the vulnerable  and deliver justice  [Music]  this is the best worst day of my life  marvel studios moon night only on disney  plus  steven  you weren't supposed to see any of this  what are you you sure you want to know  [Music]  i can't tell the difference  between my waking life and dreams  [Applause]  [Music]  am i like some sort of secret agent  it's a little more complicated than that  marvel studios moon night only on disney  plus  i can't tell the difference  between my waking life  [Music]  embrace it  you